[Music]
Ariana Grande and her husband Dalton
Gomez are going strong I'm happy life is
good a source tells E.T the singer and
her hubby are doing really well as a
married couple
[Music]
Dalton really just loves Ariana and goes
out of his way to make her happy and
show her how important she is to him
it's all romantic The Source adds that
Dalton is very supportive and constantly
cheering her on I feel your love every
day it seems the lovebirds are on
married Bliss just like waking up and
being like hell yeah you know what I
mean according to our source it's the
little things that mean the most to her
it shows her how much she really matters
to him which she really appreciates so
no matter what I'm grateful Ariana and
Dalton tied the knot back in May 2021 in
an intimate ceremony in California after
one year of dating Aries largely kept
their love life out of the spotlight
it's like I'm very sharing but I'm also
like kind of private I don't know but
earlier this year she gave fans a rare
glimpse into her romance with Dalton
with this pick of the couple sharing a
kiss it was like so crazy now while
Ariana is enjoying married life she's
also been working on the highly
anticipated film adaptation of wicked
she stars as Glinda alongside Cynthia
arivo who's taking on the role of
Elphaba it's special that the both of us
are working really really hard and we're
trying to bring you something that you
might not expect it is not going to vary
too far away hopefully from the stage
but I think you'll get more from it now
I think you'll get more of the story of
the two of these wonderful characters
who have lots of life to give yeah we
know this film will give us nothing but
great vocals from these two as for
whether we'll be getting any new music
from Ari anytime soon that's TBD but we
do know she doesn't like being away from
the stage for too long favorite part of
my tour life is seeing my fans on a
daily basis and um getting to meet and
see them not only in the meet and greet
but like just like in the audience and
like afterwards like seeing them outside
it's just like it's a very exciting
thing for us like I'm very very very
concerned about them being happy
foreign